[Music]
oh hey
that's not good at all
didn't see there on this elevator ride
all right what's up mkbhd here so as the
end of the year sort of creeps up on us
we are finally able to do like all of
our big end of the year projects like
the smartphone awards the blind camera
test and maybe a few others just because
we're feeling adventurous and so this is
one of the ones that came up that i
wanted to talk about which is just
everything that i'm carrying daily my
tech everyday carry if you want to call
it that the what's in my bag that's
something else people call it i'm just
going to call it
tech i choose
tech i've chosen now i'm going to go
through this backpack and this just so
you know this isn't the tech i carry
every single day like some people might
show a backpack and they're like yeah i
carry all this stuff all the time i
don't i'll tell you as i go through it
which stuff i carry every day and which
stuff is like for when i travel
but you'll get the idea this is
basically some of the stuff that i've
enjoyed the most that's come out this
year and i choose to use
one note is it's not always
the best
thing or the best version
of everything and that's fine i don't
need to own the highest end version of
every laptop or computer tech moves on i
have my needs met by this stuff that's
enough of a spiel uh before we get into
it though there is a little bit of a
giveaway at the end of this video so
definitely stay tuned for that if you
want to win some of this stuff all right
so let's get into it let's start with
the bag right
this is a bag
that technically this version of the bag
you can't get
so i'm going to link everything else
that i'm talking about in here down
below but this is the peak design
everyday backpack it's the 20 liter
version so the smaller version this has
been one of my favorite bags for a while
this is actually the second version
they've made
but you see the red trim up here at the
top and on some of these straps and
things like that and of course the mkbhd
logo down at the bottom this is a
version of the bag
that
they've made just 10 of for me and the
team here at the studio so
we happen to use these if you're lucky
enough that we've like given you one
because you visited the studio and we
liked you you're one of 10 and if you're
a giveaway winner you'll have one of
them but anyway this is the peak design
backpack this is a section in the thirds
there's a top middle and a bottom
oh and there's a back let's just do the
back first
all right first things first
laptop
this is the 13 inch m1 macbook pro i've
reviewed this thing
i don't edit videos on the go so again
this is not like my professional
uh video creation kit this is stuff that
i will take when i go travel or when i
need to use stuff i don't need a macbook
pro but it's just a little bit longer
battery life than the macbook air just a
little bit better of a screen and just a
little bit more annoying with the touch
bar but i love this laptop
and it has not let me down since you
guys saw the review
it's been a pretty big game changer this
year
also
in the second back sleeve here is my
tablet of choice which is the 11 inch
ipad pro
i don't feel like i need the bigger ipad
pro it's pretty close to the screen size
of the laptop
so this ipad pro it's got the icon skin
in black on black
and
this is the cellular version as well i
feel like i mostly just watched videos
on it at this point
there's a lot of other random stuff i
can do i also have done thumbnails on
the ipad which is why up top here i have
the apple pencil
but it doesn't always spend its time
attached to the tablet so i have the
apple pencil on the tablet but that's
mainly a a media thing watching videos
in the back seat of a car or just kind
of hanging around then there's a lot of
other
small pockets up here in the top of the
laptop
laptop and the top of the bag i might
have uh the mkbhd microfiber cloth in
there and i also have my headphones of
choice so i don't use headphones very
often but in a pinch the airpods are
pretty sweet i'm not a big fan of the
hardtip airpods so these are the airpods
pro and these are in icons red and black
which is dope and then i think i have a
card reader up here yep there's my card
reader so anytime you'll see the camera
in here later but anytime i take photos
and i need to read them the laptops
haven't had sd card readers in years now
so i have to have a card reader and this
is the one i keep using i've showed this
in bag videos before it's still great
and then that
is it for the back so let's get into the
front in the top is whatever i'm like
using
at the moment so for now i have my wf wf
for h
i think it's wh
w h 1000 xm4s these i don't carry every
day
these are the wireless headphones i will
not travel without so they have great
battery life great sound great noise
cancellation i've also reviewed these
anytime i'm getting on a plane anytime
i'm going to travel these go right in
the top of the backpack every single
time and then i also well i'm not doing
much else with it so if i'm bringing
food to work or from bringing a couple
extra whatever i'll put in the top of
the backpack this is a little pouch i
don't even know who makes it but i
sometimes will throw some cables in here
or something like that it's empty for
now but it just kind of hangs out in the
bag
and that's the top part i'll put my keys
in this little hidden pouch too i don't
know if you know about the peak design
hidden pouch all right so then this uh
this backpack has this pretty sweet
feature where on either side a full
length zipper
i can pop in from the side there i did
the wrong side i usually am from the
other side but that's where you get into
the middle and bottom sections of what's
in my bag
here i have my camera so this is the
canon r5 and the 15 to 35 rf lens
so
i do carry this everywhere i don't use
it all the time and it's also not the
camera i shoot with professionally often
when we're shooting video for stuff like
car videos or handheld video we'll go
with the sony a7 s3 it's just a
technically
better video camera for a lot of what we
do or even a komodo or something like
that
but i take a lot of photos so if i'm
doing photos if i'm doing thumbnails
specifically on a stills camera or if
i'm just doing instagram photos or
whatever i'm a big fan of canon's color
science of canon's images um canon r5
has been in my bag for a little while
shout out to peter mckinnon for putting
me on this camera if i do need to shoot
video in a pinch it's also pretty good
at that but i don't usually do that so
my photo camera sd card's in it already
and then
i'm already to the bottom see i told you
it wasn't much so actually let me just
go ahead and show you up here in this
little wing here is where i carry my
pens
and right now i only have two pens
and a sharpie
so if i have to sign something or write
my name on something i'll have those
easily every time i need them they're
there i also used to keep my contacts in
here before i got lasik now i literally
have eye drops that's what happens when
you change from contacts to lasik so
that's what's in the little pocket up
there
this backpack has all kinds of pockets
that i don't necessarily use that much
of but i'm still a huge fan of the bag
in case i ever do need them
then we get to the bottom
and this is the only charger
that i carry with me
so if i'm traveling i will have to add
an iphone charger
i didn't talk about my phones yet
through my pocket so i'll get to that at
the end but usbc everything so far has
been going pretty well
this is oneplus's warp charge 65 charger
it'll charge my phone but it's
compatible with almost everything else
here at up to 45 watts so this charges
the ipad this charges the macbook pro
this charges the eos r
so just this one cable and brick will do
it and it's a pretty thick wire but
that's been pretty sweet i don't have to
have the macbook pro charger and you
know the phone charger and all kinds of
other stuff in here this is my one
charger
and that's
what's in my bag
so as far as everyday carry the last
stuff you probably want to hear about
is my phone
so i am a two phone person still i've
talked about this in the past i stay in
the android world and the iphone world
pretty much on the regular i've split my
screen time between these two phones a
lot lately too and i also just realized
i have
two blue phones
this is uh the oneplus 8 pro
still in my pocket
and the iphone
12 pro
nebula blue pacific blue very different
blues but i
yeah two blue phones for me right now
like i said not always the best i don't
carry the iphone 12 pro max because that
phone
i've talked about it before but it's
huge and it's just a little too big for
for someone like me who has an ipad
already i don't need the huge screen all
the time
and for this android world obviously
this isn't the most state-of-the-art
android phone it's getting close to a
year old now but i've been a fan of the
software experience battery life's still
great camera's good enough
so these are the two phones that i've
been carrying for a little bit
and that
i think just about does it for my
current 2020
everyday tech carry okay so the giveaway
information that you all stayed so
patiently for
it's pretty simple i'm gonna be giving
away one of these bags so this actual
bag here custom one of very few mkbhd
edition peak bag
filled with
all of the tech stuff that i just
mentioned so the laptop the tablet the
camera the headphones the airpods pro
everything so you can have essentially
my daily or travel carry everyday
backpack and everything also has
perfectly installed icon skins already
on them so you're already ahead of the
game in that department if you win this
plus we're even going to throw in a few
extras so there's obviously the r5 and
the glass and everything we already
talked about in the video i'm also
tossing in an mx master three my
personal mouse of choice we're gonna
have the magic keyboard for the ipad
because it just makes sense as an
accessory alongside it there's some
other pretty sweet anchor charging
accessories in here so it's fully loaded
i guess is what i'm trying to say so if
you want to win all of this if you've
already bought anything icons you are
already entered to win so that's pretty
sweet and i'll of course have one link
below that will have all the information
all the details that you need to know to
get entered
what you should know here is it's ending
on december 24th and you should
definitely follow on twitter so if
there's any updates or any changes or
anything we need to get to you about
this giveaway it will come from twitter
so there you have it that's my everyday
tech carry that's what's in the bag
hopefully you enjoyed it or learned
something from it or got some
inspiration from it either way thanks
for watching
and i'll catch you guys very soon in the
next one
peace